[Applause]
but uh
and then they kept bringing different
types of stuff like
a fish knife oh i don't even know what
that is a specific knife just for fish
that's
not sharp so it doesn't it like kind of
just breaks the fish
and moves it and i kept thinking about
that exact thing which is like oh all
you're doing is
making up culture so you can make people
feel inferior
and it was working yeah dude it's just
thousands of years of that [ __ ] that
they didn't just come up with that
yes that's thousands of years of not
having
minorities
like the reason why america never has
this is because oh we have different
colors of people we'll just make them
feel worse and then we feel better
but in england it's all about people
they all look the exact same they've got
to start going oh well they talk a
little different okay they're poor
or oh they don't know how to use
silverware they're this it's just
structures hierarchies we're going to
put together
but even then when you get to like
wealth wealth it's still such
those guys are such evil maniacs it's
all a pissing contest who am i richer
than sure
yeah who's the classiest make up all
these little [ __ ] rules no but that's
what i'm saying but no even in america
at the wealthiest level i think that
exists they want to catch those guys
they want to show up their boys what i'm
saying is like it doesn't permeate our
entire culture
as much just because we have other ways
to like visually go
how can i feel better than you the
quickest
without using like if i want to feel
better than you in my head
all i have to do is in my head let's go
oh i know i saw you do that i'm better
than you i'm gonna invite you to dinner
i gotta give you a spoon hopefully you
don't know how to use it
and then i can go uh yeah yeah like
that's too much you know isn't it
easier just be like guys
that's what i've been doing let me ask
you this as a former
server as a former server is that the
worst feeling to feel
like inferior when when you feel like
the server's giving you [ __ ]
right like last night like he's giving
you an attitude you know what i've
realized uh
when i go into like nice clothing stores
dude
there isn't they feel like they like own
the brand
i'm like you're going to be bugs out i
went to get fitted for my suit for my
wedding and like
i felt so out of place and i was like
you make nine dollars an hour jerk off
you're making me feel like an [ __ ]
the commission off of me yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah why are you making me feel
better
like you can't even afford to [ __ ]
shop here no but you know what that [ __ ]
makes you want to buy something to like
prove
that i got money they got commissioned
yeah yeah these [ __ ] [ __ ] i know
i don't even know what you guys are
talking about
honestly i remember i walked where are
you talking about like macy's not on
sale
yeah what are you doing i walked into
uniqlo one time i walked
right the [ __ ] out they all turned their
backs to me went on break
it's a japanese brand
[Laughter]
i know also you think uniqlo is classy i
don't understand
it's [ __ ] japanese
the white ones the gray oh the
it was like before the super puff jet it
was like the you know just like the
regular ones yeah yeah and he got it
like from a friend who like stole
his friend worked security there and
stole one and fully bought for like 10
bucks or something
yeah yeah
yeah if you walk out of utica and it
beeps they just go really yeah like
really you're doing this
you have nothing else to do today you
gotta come steal a four dollar t-shirt
eat the socks
try to save face i grab a headband and
go to the counter
this will be it for today it's true man
that is true that [ __ ] inferiority
[ __ ] kind of works
yeah i wonder what that's so you kind of
respect the people who are garbage and
embrace it
absolutely oh dude that's what the whole
that's what the whole podcast is now
humble beginnings that's what it's all
about yeah it is true man
that is true what is that are they doing
that because
they also feel garbage and they're like
are they masquerading a bit who like the
super rich people that do that stuff no
like the people that work at these
really fancy places that like
will kind of be condescending is that
them projects it's their ego yeah yeah
100 100 they recognize that we both feel
the same way and they're like oh i'm not
going to let him know that
they're playing chess yeah yeah not
checkers probably think of how
terribly the really rich people treat
them yeah yeah they
if like okay here's so far beneath me
when they walk into that that's what
they're thinking yeah so they look at
the guy who's a little insecure
like they take that out on him but then
in my mind i'm going
okay in order for me to just get
borderline respect i gotta treat you
like [ __ ]
so you feel comfortable yeah yeah yeah i
have to treat you bad
so you feel comfortable with me because
you're like oh he's one of them yeah i
don't want to treat you bad
i just want to you're getting to that
point too you got to start doing that
[ __ ] no
yeah or you can just at least try it you
got to start being real snooty you
should have
you know you should have that waiter
that's what you fired last
done they were good but i knew nothing
they were walking around these [ __ ]
chains on with a little cup at the
bottom like it was literally like a pimp
cup
they all had pimp cup necklaces it was
uh they're somalias
it's a wine thing i got into a lot of
documentaries about somalia's yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like just
recently what is it called
what it's like that tom hanks thing i'm
hank's tom hanks
i miss that i'm the captain
that's garbage documentaries about
somalia
yeah read a book netflix culture over
here i'm trash well i mean i'm not
sitting here like i'm a [ __ ] king of
england dude i am garbage
it's okay to condition every day he's
still trying to cut me down at the legs
so apparently i asked the lady right i
just go
why does everybody have the chain with
the with the cup
and i because i thought that made them
like the best server
like a few of them i thought they were
the super surf hey congratulations
how do you say like taste of wine in
french test
or something like that basically for
years they would have it you'd take a
little sip and that's how like the
somalia is no
and i was like okay so she but she
didn't make me feel bad or anything like
that that's nice yeah you get a bottle
say what did you get a bottle they tried
to hit me with that wine pairing
yeah see you're garbage
i couldn't do it no i'm not doing that
yeah yeah somebody get a name still
light whatever she wants
oh the guy i need more bread over here
is that
garden asking for more bread yeah yeah
for more bread
hey honey how about a couple more parker
houses over here i said this oh my god i
said i was so stuck i didn't eat the
whole day we came in here to do the
pockets
the whole day i went there and i sit
down and they come over and the person
goes she hits me with you know the
classic line and
first of all the busboy comes in and
asks about the water is if you say no to
bottled to like
not even the waiter always say yes to
the bottle you get the bottle no i said
tap
but yeah big tap guy big tape
i love it so i go i go i'll take tap but
i'm shaking i'm so hungry i'm literally
shaking right and then i go
this is a fancy [ __ ] restaurant i got
a calamari here quick
can we start you out with an appetite or
something like that i got a sample it
comes out of my mouth i go
man i'm just so hungry can i get some
bread or something like this
you are such a mook dude
you got any rolls back there
rodolfo get the gentleman some rose and
then i stopped myself and i was like oh
actually i'll just wait like maybe
she'll have something
it sucks why the [ __ ] do i feel
embarrassed in this place
at that joint i'm trying to think of
because i go into those places and i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ]
yeah i think i'm so used to being
insecure that i'm like you're not going
to make it worse
yeah you're so secure he's fighting yeah
i'm used to happening no that is
actually true like don't get me wrong
we all have our super insecure moments
whatever but in most environments i feel
very
confident i do and i will i'll be honest
but in certain places
i feel out of place and it's like almost
hard for me to like
talk it's so weird that's a trap you're
free you're not
used to feeling like an imposter you
walk into these rich places you feel
like an impossible yes
i feel like an imposter every day baby
he's in there he doesn't even feel
comfortable in the bodega he's in there
like how much for a honey bun
never eaten at a place like this but
this is garbage garbage if a place
like a nice italian restaurant gives you
bread i'll be like yo can we get some
bread to take home
oh [ __ ] yeah if you got sauce i want my
leftovers
this is another this is another big
divisive one it's leftovers i think
taking leftovers is trash this [ __ ]
guy
it is oh dude no you pay for the
experience i sit there and if you don't
finish your meal you wouldn't
stop [ __ ] you're the guy who can't
finish you order up the kid's menu next
time
you're sitting here you can't finish
your chicken chicken you can't finish a
chicken breast
and a potato what thing you're calling
what
what the [ __ ] is this in your hair let's
get him the [ __ ] out of here
you're nuts no that's funny oh you could
have finished your
meal can i get him a sprite with no ice
and a lid too please
[Laughter]
he doesn't get it see when him and his
girl go eat they eat in a very german
military way they tell you something
they each get their own
is taking home leftovers is not about he
orders a third entree
he doesn't [ __ ] hey there's no actual
leftovers an appetizer in the meal is
hard
yes he's going to go he goes let me get
a chicken parm on the way he ordered two
for me
for himself he's a big guy somebody was
coming he didn't get his [ __ ]
eating salad dude hit me late i was like
is he on a date
he already have two there's another guy
coming i swear
he's ordering the office he's ordering
three drinks to confuse them guess
oh yeah no when me and my girl go out to
dinner
[Laughter]
he goes we'll have he orders with wool
for the table
we'll start with the appetizer sampler
can you put it on four plates please i
want to share with everybody
no when me and my girl go have to eat we
get an appetizer we each get an entree
there's leftovers i'm sure you and your
girl do the same thing absolutely he
just gets the bare minimum
he's eating like a [ __ ] coal miner
dude i finished my meal i'm paying
but you know if we're going out to a
nice place we're paying a lot of money
yeah man you go and you leave you take
this is insane it's not virtual reality
over here
we dug into this because you would take
it home and give it to your dog
that's literally how it started in like
world war one did you take any leftovers
home last night not for human
consumption
that's animalistic you're so
this is pre-microwave pre-oven pre the
ability
free air fryer for a dog dude it's four
originally for a dog
back in the day exactly he's actually
bringing up
[ __ ] a scallop on top take a hike
[ __ ] that it's not a dog nobody calls it
a doggy bag anymore
[ __ ] fred flintstone over here food
and he's still on the meal
you should eat it or not and he's still
like no i'm not giving my
dog any of my leftovers
what are you [ __ ] crazy
you hear me mittens you hear me ah okay
is this garbage ready
you guys are talking about leftovers
last night
uh i would it was a chef's tasting right
so they like have the menu uh
already set up yes right i would finish
mine
okay my girl there's like a bite or two
left
right and they would come to take her
plate and then i would say
i'll finish it and then because they
didn't want me to like just
slide the plate over sure they would
like pick it up and make like a thing of
it and like bring it over to me
is that garbage at a fancy restaurant i
don't think that should be guarded it's
jesus yeah
no isn't it more respectful to the chef
like i don't want to waste your
delicious food that's great yeah i
yeah i don't know i think that's just
like i if i was
i would have eaten it before they came
over to take it you know what i mean i
would have been like yeah
yeah i wouldn't hear that yeah that's
true yeah it's all it's all i don't know
it's all the thing that chain you're
coming
[Laughter]
right i acted like i planned it months
in advance i got a resident bubba gumps
you cool with that
hold on whole thing is ruined because
when i put the [ __ ] reservation in
i have to use her rezzy uh thing yeah
yeah
and then it gives her a notification oh
you're a smart guy you set this whole
thing up you're getting caught by the
rezzy app
bro what the [ __ ] because i had my
uh he knows you're too stupid to cheat
just download your own app
dude you built this amazing studio
download an app here's the thing
my boy this is my boy he can like uh he
works at one of these uh services they
get you [ __ ]
yeah concierge he has a concierge right
and uh so he hooked it up and he goes yo
i
gave your girl's number instead of yours
you know i don't want to like give your
number out or whatever no i don't think
anybody cares about the number of this
place
but then i've been telling my girl i
planned this for weeks and she gets the
so i'm going to her the rest of the days
like yeah playing this whatever she's
like oh but after i do this whole spiel
about yeah you know
i wanted something nice for us whatever
like just out of curiosity why did i get
a reservation thing today
from rezzy did you try to like backtrack
and be like well they didn't convert it
in today
they asked me for cobit testing that's
what i said nice yo
hey but you you did lie i won't be yeah
i lied that's great
good for you he ain't making it this
deep into the podcast she'll skip the
first 10 minutes
i put all the heat at the back end i've
learned this i've learned this
30 minutes
it's like a fed wiretap they got they
got to stop listening if they don't hear
their name in five minutes
[Applause]